in this episode of coffee with canel
we're going to be talking about what is
working on YouTube right now what are
the best ways to get views what are the
best ways to come up with video ideas
and what are the best ways to generate
new subscribers especially in a 2024
World I actually want to show you a
quick hack though this is pretty well
known but if you haven't seen inside of
your YouTube dashboard you can go to
content analytics overview content
audience Revenue research and if you
click on Research kind of a cool little
tool here that allows you to actually
enter a search topic and YouTube will
give you data back on the specific query
query so imagine if you had a channel
that was about bass fishing you can
actually type in bass fishing and then
it'll break down the search volume of
certain terms fall bass fishing spart
strategic time to always do things
seasonally um October a specific month
maybe you wouldn't have thought to use
the month in your title but what we're
going to be doing here is making
datadriven decisions based B on Research
just from a cool tool that YouTube gives
you free now I'm logged into our think
media channel if I go to your viewer
searches um this also once you have
viewers once you have an audience it'll
actually give you some feedback on some
of the top Search terms that your
viewers would be interested in you'll
notice that I actually saved one how to
start a YouTube channel now I've talked
about that extensively as his Nolan but
it just reminds me that especially in a
new year that it's good to double down
on some of the classic zve pen the Sony
camera that's not only have we doubled
down on that series but we should double
down more because when you're tapped in
and there's three pages of results here
when you're tapped into what viewers
actually want that's when you start
getting the best results possible so
anyways just wanted to give you that
quick tip right at the start of coffee
with canel today smash like if you're
fired up for the show we have two guests
from our V Elite program we're going to
be doing some coaching that you can
benefit from we've got some special
announcements a lot of cool things
coming up on the coffee with canel show
[Music]
welcome back to the coffee with canel
show let the adventure begin mug brought
to you by black and white coffee Ro
Roasters who uh I'm sipping on I don't
know what blend this is but I just made
it for the show let me know what you're
drinking if you're here live um and and
uh want to shout you out wherever you're
watching from um by the way today's
episode is brought to you by the tube 1K
challenge shout me out if you're a part
of the challenge tube 1K challenge.com
we started day one but we do have
limited replays available five days 10
sessions 10 tips technically five full
length sessions 10 quick tips special
guests free giveaways if you haven't
heard about it yet you got to go to tube
1K challenge.com that is happening and
there's still time to catch up on the
material in there to1 K challenge.com as
the URL check that out in the
description down below today's episode
is also B brought to you by streamyard
but I'll tell you a little bit more
about them later and with that we're g
to get into Mike our first guest so Mike
welcome to the show and break down a
little bit about your background and
what you do on YouTube yeah thanks for
having me uh we teach how to grow micro
greens business specifically uh so very
niched down into that and we've run a
sucessful business for three plus years
so now we're teaching others how to do
it and do it the right way that's
amazing and when did you start the
channel uh 2021 I think it's been two
years now that's amazing 150,000 views
on the channel started in 2021 how long
have you been doing the biddy micro Farm
or or micro greens uh a little bit over
three years now wow and 115 uploads is
that a lot of shorts or what is that
attributed to uh a lot of it is shorts
off of our podcast that we've started
doing with another grower so a lot of it
is shorts uh but it is uh some long form
for format as well that's amazing and so
far who's working on the production of
this Channel all all things included uh
myself and my wife um and then we have
the one co-host that does the podcast
with us but he just shows up and does
the podcast gotcha so who cuts up the
shorts uh Opus Clips
actually good call to action right there
not that it's call to action but we'll
definitely link to them Opus Clips is uh
is really fun it's it's doing the
captions for you right dist all that
stuff yeah finding the clips and so how
much energy does that take you uh not
much I just click the link to put it
over there and then I download them and
put them on because you set the template
up that you want on them and it just
does it so it works perfect that's
beautiful and then if you look at
something like this it looks like these
were these not Opus these two they were
not Opus them were older ones yeah yeah
exactly so in the top five three of them
were Opus by using AI by using software
1100 views 1500 1900 that's really cool
awesome well what's your question today
uh well been working on thumbnails being
in V Elite uh one of the big things is
thumbnails they just did a workshop on
that and so we've been changing the
thumbnails uh and just kind of are we on
the right path got it yeah yeah these
are uh they are I can see the pivot we
see the personalization of you I also
see the brand colors meaning it's the
yellow so we kind of have that split
screen getting feedback where do you fit
that one really captures my attention
because of the pie chart and by asking
me a question question it just it it it
immediately hit my
curiosity um micro greens competitors
with strong branding I think they're
good yeah I think that uh um for
educational content they they're very
clear we're trying to have three or less
words typically um I think what's
actually more interesting it's kind of
just a big idea strategy for you for
everybody that's smart enough to be a
part of this show you know
one of the big things that is
interesting about YouTube right
now is there's an unfair advantage or a
huge opportunity with what I would argue
as long form
content and to Define long form I
wouldn't pin it down with a specific
number but I would say this it's
probably over 12 minutes and as long as
30 or more so there's something about
rich longer form content and I guess the
reason I say that is it's just something
to think about I'm kind of pivoting my
advice because these look great but at
only 3 minutes or 137 we've been doing a
lot of Clips as well I'm not a big fan
of the 137 or the two minute 20 second
clip okay I'm not I'm seeing them not do
well partly just because the
total amount of minutes watched can't
even be that much yeah and maybe the
best way to kind of just emphasize Ultra
long
form would
be let me go to a live stream and I have
to go a little older so that I can look
at the
data I'm gonna look at a live stream
that was a few months
ago that was an hour and nine
minutes
so this did incredibly well for our
Channel mind you add Revenue $1,000 500
subscribers 50,000 views over time it's
still getting views even though it's
older it's an hour and 9 Minutes at
average percentage viewed pretty bad 17%
it's absolutely
terrible however average view duration
12 minutes and 21 seconds now how many
shorts fit inside of 12 minutes and 21
seconds you know what I mean like if
somebody watches 20 seconds of a short
and then swipes like quite literally
whether someone's spending their time in
the short feed or they're spending their
time watching two-minute videos that's
six two-minute videos 12 minutes time 60
is 700 12 seconds divided by 202 short
the 36 shorts is the average amount of
time I'm able to hold the attention of
all 50,000 people that watch this so of
course some watch till the end some skip
out towards the beginning and it
averages down to 12 minutes that tells
YouTube that wow this piece of content
is holding the average person's
attention for 12 minutes that's just to
make the point and I've never
articulated it and that's why the coffee
with candle show is a a no Miss show is
just just to think about not fluffing
your content up but what longer form
content could you create and I I guess
the second dimension of that is I would
also argue that it's not a video podcast
you could continue to do video podcasts
those could also do well like this one
but but what I'm looking for is I think
you have a big
opportunity to let's say teach in front
of a whiteboard for 20 minutes and break
down a business model let's say like
like something rich the right title the
right information it also could be
something like this where I'm sharing my
screen but you it's you're you're brief
you're bright you're fun and done but
it's 25 minutes long and it's like the
biggest amount of you know really gritty
information that business owners and
micr greens who want to know but also
broad appeal just try that out I think I
we're seeing it across the board too is
that there's just something about three
minutes two minute Clips they can do all
right but that's that I feel like
they're capped because they just don't
have the chance of getting as much
average view duration does that make
sense yeah makes sense yeah because
they're not getting much views and it's
it's showing out so yeah and then let's
check out popular here this makes sense
I mean if I if you think about this too
if I click on the tour what do I want to
watch the tour so I mean it's like you
think about intent eight minutes I
probably want to watch the whole thing
maybe the other person just to uh close
uh even what long form could mean do it
on a dime is coming on the uh fake media
podcast soon so make sure you're
subscribed depending on where you're
watching this and she said long form
dial videos for her are killing and I
said what's long form well it's always
longer than 8 minutes as you can see um
it's 10 minutes it's 11 minutes and
these are like power packed which one
was the last one I watched
50 new Dollar Tree deals you need to buy
in 2023 think about this 11 minutes long
50 deals boom editing boom energy
getting through the content 264,000
views so um anyways that by when I say
long form it's like it's like I'm all
for video podcasting I'm all
for shorts I'm all for these different
content
formats but I think you know how to grow
broccoli micr greens step by step if you
brought some of these back and I learn
in five minutes or if you don't fluff it
up you don't double it to 10 for no
reason but you double it to 10 for more
detail and new hacks and New Tricks I
think that that becomes really
interesting in terms of uh it performing
really well and we can learn here of
course and popular that you know some of
the one-year-old two-year-old videos
might be worth revisiting with your
skill sets um what other questions you
have oh no that's uh pretty much you
know the thumbnails and getting more
clickr rates and uh uping up the channel
to get more views uh so yeah I think you
pretty much covered everything that I
had have you done like um answer the
public or things like that oh yeah who's
your target audience uh micine business
owners yeah I mean people that to start
a micr game business one of the things I
think you have to accept is is also just
being like self-aware and and really
avoiding comparison because when you
tell me your target audience is like
micro green business owners and you're
and and you're not saying this but
you're like and I just don't get why I'm
going not going viral well there's like
no such thing I mean like the maximum
amount uh you know what I mean like
that's it's a small Niche I think that
probably makes sense but um and so what
I do think is interesting though is
almost defining like levels to like cap
like how to boost market share of micr
greens that is like a six viewed video
now as you grow it could may maybe be
like a 300 600 viewed video but it's not
going to be 100,000 viewed video my
question becomes what could be your a
banger video that has a little bit more
broad appeal
and and and let me ask you this would
you want to avoid consumers and just
attract business
owners uh no you know anybody who's
interested in microgreens would be uh a
Target as well I guess guess yeah so
this is interesting I typed in micro
greens using just the search bar I I
like this micro green like micr green
for profit is
interesting that's one of my next videos
I'm working on great yeah that's that's
amazing this is a good thumbnail good
obviously you can see he's legit he's in
there whatever he's hold the stuff uh
that's a good one too from basement to
bake roll is a little weird of a front
it's almost like chat gbt wrote that but
fine jaw drop but like almost like this
would this title could in my opinion
it's just a good video I think this is
the title I think I think $20,000
monthly income from micr Green farmer
how he did it or something like that so
success leaves Clues you're already
doing that and that's smart so that's
great but um I think that thinking about
some of those things where those are
going to be if you tap into the desires
of the market or maybe some micro green
for profit like pre- business owner or
pre- knowing I could even make money
thinking about some of those broad
appeal topics there are some
64,000 690,000 like that's a
lifechanging video agree yeah those kind
of views yeah you got that in you you
could you can do this but also it's not
a video podcast no no you know what I
mean it's not a clip it's it's a crafted
video yeah that's that's I think
probably the interesting move you're
good at titles and thumbnails I think
it's about adding some videos to your
library uh
that are like of course you're shooting
for the stars but if it gets 6,000 views
it's better than the views we're getting
now but if it gets 60,000 and then you
know it's really interesting and then
you you repeat that process I think you
could really build it up like somebody
like Donnie greens and other people who
I'm sure you know for sure yep going
through your V Masters right now through
the elite and kind of laying everything
out in this next video so awesome Mike
well I appreciate you so much grateful
for you thanks for being a part of what
we're doing and being a part of V Elite
and keep crushing it inspired by what
you're doing doing thank you appreciate
it all right friends listen we got
another guest here Glenn's coming up in
a second I forgot to mention we also do
Q&A so if you have a question you can
put four question marks before and after
the question we'll star those as we go
along uh let me know if you got a
question about anything we'll get to a
couple of those we're g to bring on
Glenn in a second but I'm going to take
a uh sip of my coffee while we have a
word from our sponsor this episode is
brought to you by streamyard streamyard
is our go-to platform form here at think
media for live streaming to Facebook and
YouTube and for recording our video
podcast it has an incredibly easy to use
interface for built-in branding
transitions text lower thirds and
seamlessly bringing on guests and they
just added an awesome new feature called
local recording this allows you to take
the quality to another level by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests giving you more control over
your content for later use this feature
is perfect for video and podcast
creators and so to get a special deal on
streamyard right now and to see all the
features that are included just go to
streami think.com that is streami
think.com one of my favorite things
about streamyard is the fact that from
my home office with my son three
sleeping in the other room and my son
one sleeping in the bathroom sounds kind
of funny we literally don't have a room
for him but like the fan in there and we
can close the door and the sound they're
both taking naps right now but while
they're taking naps I can hang out with
people like Mike and Glenn and uh stream
from wherever we're running our
challenge with streamyard right now
super helpful to bring on multiple
people so many cool features so if you
want to check it out stream withth
think.com all the notes are in the show
notes are in the description as usual so
always take advantage of what's
Happening down there and um we're going
to go to Glenn in just a second after a
question question from architectural
sheet metal 101 how much time should we
set aside for
ideation it's a good question I like
that
question I think that the big the the
better
question is as follows I would think
about three things number one how much
time do you have before I even ask that
question the first question I'd ask how
much time do you have because we have
people of all different
backgrounds I would prefer if you come
to me and you're like Sean I'm a
business owner I want to start creating
content I want to start YouTube I can
get you an hour a week I'm gonna work
with your hour I can get you five hours
a week I'm gonna work with your five
hours and based on how much time you
have is how we're going to split up your
time the second question is how much are
you you executing and how well are you
executing
because as I actually get to your actual
question I would love to I think we
should increase the amount of time on
strategy thinking
ideation because sometimes it gets a bad
rap like there's that quote that says
success is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration you got to put in the work
you got to rise and grind you got to
hustle yeah but also there's a lot of
people who work really really really
really really really hard and the
results suffer they need to be working
smarter more strategic better ideas
better
ideation
so if you have time number one and if
you are executing and and the results
show it you are publishing you are
producing you have momentum even better
if you've got a little bit of margin a
little bit of money a little bit of
momentum well now would argue how much
time should you set aside for ideation a
lot and here's what ideation is to me
going for a walk is ideation reading
books is ideation going to cool places
on the Las Vegas Strip and getting
inspired as ideation going to events is
ideation because talking on coffee with
canel to guess is like even though we
are actually creating content right now
there's a lot of things that go into
good ideation many of which don't just
have to do with sitting down in front of
it I Q or something that helps too you
experiencing and immersing yourself into
the world and into the culture of your
viewers you reading books directly
related to your Niche adjacent to your
Niche and unrelated to your Niche all
these different things create
connections between synapses fire off
different nuro Pathways that Inspire our
minds spark our spirits and help us
produce our best content possible and
success might be 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration but that 1% is pretty dang
import important I'm not a big like
manifest things guy sorry for anybody
that's that's respect if that's your
thing like I'm not a big like Law of
Attraction guy
because uh sometimes the idea of that
stuff is like man I was just dreaming it
up and then I saw a car in my driveway
and people who probably really know that
like no no no that's not what it is but
people that literally like I'm just
attracting abundance into my life like
no you're not you're lazy like
ultimately you you you get results by
working however your thought
life
your the book Think and Grow Rich is
true like if you don't think it first
like how you think thoughts become you
know behaviors behaviors become actions
actions become habits well they have to
actually translate so if we do need to
think better and if we think smarter
clearer we come up with better ideas
then the work we put behind those ideas
is better so I hope that's helpful I
think some of the things for ideation
can also produce a lot of Health nature
get away from the computer get in some
conversations with some real people buy
a plane ticket fly to an event and and
and what you come back with a lot of
time is next level idation you got to
create margin for that smash like if
you're getting
value and uh I want to shout out uh
we're going to Glenn here next and we
got some good questions coming in so
thank you for all your questions this is
the coffee with canel show and our next
guest is Glenn and Glenn is from Science
music videos Glenn tell us a little bit
about your story when did you start this
Channel and what is it you do I uploaded
my first video in 2008 um so uh I've
been a career high school biology
teacher um I've always had a unique
thing which is that uh since about my
second day in the classroom I've been
writing songs and bringing my guitar
into the classroom to sing them with my
students and so yeah that's my first
that's my first video 2008 that's what I
look like way back then it's not really
too different um but anyhow uh in 1987
the bar for creating video and getting
it out to the world was pretty high in
200 whatever when YouTube started that
dramatically lowered so um I had a
little bit of time on my hands I made my
first YouTube video I made another one
another one went kind of viral it's
called the sell song it's one of my
earliest um videos it's got about three
million views
um and uh so then that got monetized and
then I created a website to support
teachers who were using the uh songs
with their students and that um goes
with another interest of mine I've
always been interested in computer uh
assisted learning and so I created a
website that now has grown to be a full
AP biology curriculum I sell that to
teachers and schools and uh I retired
from the classroom in June so that I
could do YouTube and Business
Development full-time uh so that's kind
of where I'm at and um do you want to
hear my question you have questions for
me where do we go now yeah I'm gonna ask
your a question in just a second but
first of all I just want to acknowledge
you you know what's kind of cool is I
feel like we're talking to a legend here
the fact you've been doing video pre
YouTube and all that I dip my toes into
it in 2003 but you've been in the game
but but you've got more hits than Drake
I mean we've got you've got five videos
over a million views yeah and one that's
on its way there so that's super cool
it's cool to see the history um and then
I love the biz Dev aspect so I just
wanted to be clear is this where that no
go back to learn Das biology that's that
I mean that's part of it biom Mania is
my app so that's an app that um is
really tightly coordinated with what
you're looking at over there which is my
website and my market now in terms of
who I'm successful with has been
teachers in schools and um I sell to
teachers and schools okay I mean I could
grow much much further in that market um
but what I'm really hungry to move into
is that there there are 250,000 kids who
take the AP Bio exam every single year
there are another 180,000 who take IB
bio and another 250,000 who are freshman
College biology students I want to sell
to those individuals and their families
I want to get their parents to buy
individual subscriptions and I've set
some of that up on my website so that's
kind of like the very end of the funnel
I haven't quite figured out how to
create a customer experience that's
going to move someone from awareness of
what I'm doing to making a purchase and
that's that's really um why I joined Dr
Elite to figure that
out okay great so then is that the
question too how can we move different
audiences to the purchase that is that
is the main qu that is that is one of my
biggest questions I mean I also have
like very very sort of more tactical
questions you know I sort of have a new
style of video that I'm making now I
really focused on a good hook and um I'm
not sure if that's really if I'm pulling
that off well if we have time you could
look at my latest video see how I'm
doing on that but um really the the
Strategic stuff how do I create that
customer experience is what I'm
interested in so I think that I've got
some this in a way I would probably
start with the bizdev conversation kind
of a higher level marketing
conversation um
and is how I mean is revenue going
okay I mean um let's see I'm a five fig
business with teachers and um with
teachers in schools so I I could be much
much bigger than that um so not even at
six figures yet um and we have really
anemic sales to individuals but partly
that's because I haven't figured out how
to do that marketing and do that
Outreach so that's kind of where we're
at like the initial thing the big idea
number one that I look at with what
you're doing
is is I feel like getting
help um
or there's two ways to do it you just
put in your Sweat Equity and you work on
it yourself but by getting help this
thing could scale pretty significantly
and help with what well what's
interesting to me is you mentioned like
five audiences that was like a red flag
to me positive on the macro but like one
website for five audiences seems kind of
tough because you're like I want parents
to buy I want students to buy was that
accurate did I hear you hear you say
that they're all buying the same thing
so what you're looking at is an
interactive biology textbook with
quizzes and flashed cards and
interactive diagrams that makes learning
a million times more effective than a
textbook and it can really take you from
despair to Mastery so that's that's
really what I'm trying to do parents are
just going to buy it for their kids kids
aren't going to buy it themselves so I
really have two markets teachers and
then so it's like it's like a businesso
business which is teachers and business
to Consumer which is students but my
guess is that the parents are going to
be be paying the money to buy the
subscription okay fair enough and so I
think one of the things that could be
helpful is even still creating I'm sure
you're familiar with the word
funnel the average business owner needs
more than one funnel and I think that's
the idea here what I what I feel like is
a missing piece is we're going to one
website I don't love the website it's
not super clear a guarantee four or five
on the AP exam or your money back learn
by ology there's kind of even this
picture this text start your free trial
student subscription it's fine but I
think it could really be improved and
what I also think the idea of even
studying funnels is funnels are a 100
times more powerful than
websites because what a funnel is is
more of a journey than it is a static
page and the reason a journey is
powerful is somebody could watch you
could craft a YouTube video that is
perfect for teachers you then could
offer them something that's not a
website but is something free in
exchange for their contact
information what you also then know
about the person that signed up with
their contact information on a specific
funnel is you just know where that
person is where their mentality is what
they what they're doing so therefore
your followup with them can be perfectly
aligned with them as a market as opposed
to one website
and then the touch points along that
Journey can continue towards a potential
sales
conversation and so right now YouTube to
just one website is getting you like you
said pretty flat sales it's like 1% of
the power it could be if it was powered
up to 100% let me make an analogy that
is also we're seeing be incredibly
effective here number one uh ethic media
our promise is YouTube so we do free
class on YouTube but we've also kind of
struggled if if you will in the past I
wouldn't say struggle but we've always
had multiple audiences two in particular
the Creator aspiring hobbyist YouTube
creator that wants to go full-time in
the Creator economy and the business
owner that wants leads clients in sales
now my teaching Style on the way we
Market Pages because at least the one
thing they all want to learn is YouTube
it has worked but what we've been doing
lately is like for example we recently
did a class for Christian content
creators we would call this Niche
marketing but not Niche products you
said you have one product but what would
be helpful is to have Niche marketing
because as soon as I talk to Christian
content creators and I have another one
coming up for Real Estate another one
coming up for network marketing another
one coming up for entrepreneur small
business owners is as soon as like you
know who you're talking to it really
like clarifies the conversation but then
they feel a lot more alignment as well
and then we're also going to creating
some bonuses that actually onboard
people into that want to join us inside
of like our paid stuff into our
programs
um with their unique pain points because
if I'm a real estate starting on YouTube
agent I'm going to approach it different
for the Christian content creator I
honestly think about like the Theology
of content creation is it okay to
self-promotion toxic ambition versus
Godly ambition like there's other things
that come along with it I guess my point
is think about if you were to
do uh some trial of some kind or
something that gets the students a quick
result and you get the contact
information of the parents you figure
all of that stuff out that also then
just helps you it's just in a way it's
modern
marketing the internet is too busy that
without capturing somebody's contact
information and getting the permission
to continue to communicate with them
you're kind of in trouble when it comes
to sales because they see one YouTube
video but if they're hungry and you
create a desirous enough free gift of
some kind
that then you're sending someone to a
funnel so for example our website is
actually frankly embarrassing shanel.com
but it's functional it's fine but we
almost never people probably wonder why
do you never send anybody to your
website it's like well I don't think
websites are that important I think
what's more important is the
conversation with an individual person
YouTube video join me in a challenge
join me in a webinar download my free
gear guide download the first chapter of
YouTube Secrets a million different
things we do um but when someone signs
up and now but think about that that's
one thing we like okay I know they were
interested in the first chapter of my
book but when they sign up for a YouTube
for real estate agents web class what
does that tell us about everybody that
signed up for that like it's think about
that curated list it's the most powerful
thing in the world because now also we
don't even just have to put generic
information in regards to the email
follow-up sequence we know we're talking
to real estate agent so I can hyperfocus
my advice and there can be much more
alignment and as a result
um it it also UPS conversions and sales
so
ultimately I think if I'm you those are
some of the things I'm trying to build
but what that's why I also mentioned
help because I think about who not how
could you know if you got something like
kajabi or something like clickfunnels or
something like that and and there
there's we don't have time for it today
but even just best practices on the page
and some different things like there's a
difference between this is obviously a
website and it's fine it's functional as
a website but the problem with websites
is like we get here we read this we go
through here there's too many things to
do back to my point about a funnel is
there's only one thing to do it's like
watch video land on page one Action Sign
up for the class download the thing buy
the book buy the I mean there's so many
marketing things you could actually how
much is your um your
offer to teach teachers to parents to
there are different prices there are
different a kid pays out of pocket a kid
buys it it's uh $59 with the app for a
parent it's $199 because they have
monitoring tools where they can see what
work their students have done um their
kids have done and for teachers it's um
also 199 if they pay out of pocket 349
if the school buys it for them and then
we also have like multiple teacher
licenses and things like that beautiful
yeah I think some of that you explaining
it makes sense this page the amount of
text on the page how blocked together it
is tier one tier two tier
three using
a analogy appr propo to your
Niche everything on the internet needs
to be like fifth grade reading level and
fifth grade response uh complexity level
back to funnels like what do I do next
where do I go next what is it I'm doing
what what am I signing up for where do I
buy and this would also tap into the
term called e-commerce and lots of
people have learned things about Shopify
stores even the opportunity to to
perhaps start with the form and the form
says okay are you a teacher student or a
student okay great are you yes I'm that
okay 1999 is your thing they don't have
to see everything like they fill out
like like a progressive so again back to
it there is we could talk a long time
about online marketing best practices
ways to set up your online business ways
to structure your sales Pages your
funnels your messaging your websites
plural meaning different funnels getting
of course and also you don't need to
build 30 funnels what you need to build
is one that is highly profitable that
pushes you over six figures that also
then makes it possible to if I'm you I'd
reinvest in people because everything I
just described while I have grown
and from Reading from studying from
being a practitioner I have learned the
nuances of what I'm describing to you
let me be clear the only way I can stay
sane and do what I'm doing and and
juggle the content creation and life in
general is from
hiring and even early early on shout out
to Heather Tores she came in and even
though I was able to build out an online
course in kajabi I was flat out and and
the emails and the landing pages and
stuff she came on with the chance check
this out
of performance-based compensation and
originally performance-based only so if
you said Sean I can't hire I would
challenge you and I would say what if
you found somebody that could help you
build out the 3.0 version of all of this
stuff and you said hey I'll give you
um I want to say was the first year it
might have been 10% might have been 20%
by the way only that was and then it was
renegotiated eventually went lower once
she got a salary but when we first
started it was like only on if our thing
sold so what's the risk now you get the
right person that is a win-win win
because if they're entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial they say okay so great
so if we
do six figures in sales and I get 20% I
make $20,000 well let me ask you if we
could just snap our fingers and generate
you another six figures would you pay
20,000 to have somebody help you do that
sure so that I think gets interesting
because you can you apps not only can
you you could set up a tool kajabi
clickfunnels there's all different ones
and and start
if you will building out some sales
processes or funnels that could could be
helpful to this the one other thing I
think is um but but getting help is
going to be better so you could focus on
the creating of the content
Etc I think another interesting thing is
are you doing shorts I am how are those
going not I mean it's too it's
completely variable I I really can't
make out why some are super popular
and some don't do anything um and you
know the revenue is ridiculously low
from what's coming in I I mostly sort of
see them as advertising for myself and
also frankly and I know this runs a
danger of overextension I really like
hitting other platforms and if I make
vertical videos I can hit those other
platforms Tik Tock um Instagram stuff
like that so what I also I mean this is
also another kind of marketing strategy
that sort of steps outside of you
YouTube what I think would be super
fascinating this is a highle
strategy is how many students do you
have how many students do I have yeah
already maybe a hundred but I I mean it
it depends on how you qualify that
teachers through students I have about
7,000 but you know that means about 130
teachers with 7,000 students but
individual students who have paid only
about a hundred actually I think you ugc
is a massive opportunity for you what's
that user generated
content so what I think is interesting
because we wanted to still down what is
the value proposition and everybody
watching coffee canel these are good
conversations to lean in for because
we're talking highlevel
marketing you want to if you create a
product and you want one for your
YouTube channel too but a value
proposition to me you have an incredible
value proposition I'm going to give you
a guaranteed four or five on the AP exam
or your money
back right that's right that's a great
value prop and also for 20 bucks like
okay I'm about to spend $20 it in and
out like I mean it's like okay I'm G
just intermit it fast and uh Ace my um
my AP exam okay so user generated
content would be could I get someone
that has purchased my product and taken
the exam
to create content for
me now on a basic level this would be
like a video
testimonial that is in and of itself
probably not going to perform well but
that's worth doing as well in fact on
this website this would get me a lot
more pumped if I could just click on a
video and it was like all I did was I
bought this and then I like a you know
whatever so you could use those assets
for a lot of different things but when I
think about user generated content what
I'm more interested in is understanding
that in today's world people are pretty
sophisticated on their smartphones a
percentage of people are they know how
to let's say Vlog a little bit do a
daily Vlog in their stories you know
they know how to do a voiceover on their
Instagram real so someone goes to
college and they're like hey guys back
to my day in the life I woke up this
morning and I had collagen plus and my
shaker bottle was so good then I went to
the gym then I went to my AP class and I
had a huge exam today and I nailed it I
actually got a four on the exam that was
actually because of the help of um
Science music videos took their course
so cool and my parents were super pumped
and then it like shows with the parents
because you could do that on Instagram
reals or YouTube shorts by like
narrating a voice over and shooting the
b-roll throughout the
day imagine if you had asset creative
assets from your community talking about
promoting your
product now
imagine you in in doing so what would it
be worth to you to have a great video
now now if we back up a little bit
imagine if it's a
teacher uh hey Miss Travis here I you
know teach in such and such State and I
teach biology um and of course my
passion is to see my students win but
I've been looking for a way to like get
this stuff to stick and get them to
actually Crush their AP exams what I
actually found was I found this resource
what was cool about it is I just open it
up I went through it and I passed along
I don't know because I don't fully
understand what you're doing yet but
like exactly how it's executed but now
imagine you had that video and not only
could you post it on your shorts on the
other platforms as you do and maybe it
does all right organically but once
you've tested and proven that it works
you could put paid advertising behind it
this I'm really encouraged because
you're like I'm working my way to get to
figures six figures is no problem for
you on the other side of world class
execution of modern
marketing really easy to say not even
necessarily easy to say it takes a level
of skill to even articulate it but it's
but it easy to say harder to do but if
we were in a situation with some ugc
videos user generated content five of
them two are okay two do all right one
does really well paid ads behind them an
agency runs that or someone internal to
a sales page in a funnel that's better
than this current website because it
it's optimized for who's Landing there
what they see there's not a bunch of
options it drives directly to a sale at
that point Facebook ads Tik Tok ads you
might be seeing these I'm seeing like
dror squash ads that are like weird
things that's a soap and it's like do
you want to smell you know like it's
kind of and then there's it's it's ugc
influencer not even probably product
users that they're
hiring that they're running content
against my a little bit of it takes
chops to execute what I'm saying but on
the other side of that all dialed in is
you know 102k a month 200k 300K a year
is not that far out of
reach um and then obviously the ad cost
that goes behind that as well um but
what I Al but what makes me think about
that is we're let's what are we solving
for we're coming all the way back to
trying to solve for how do I convert
more sales and the organic YouTube play
will continue to help you with that and
V Elite and all that stuff that's all
great but I thought it'd be interesting
to take this conversation to a higher
level marketing conversation because it
depends on what we're trying to do do we
just want to get more views on YouTube
that's great too or do we want to get to
a quarter million dollars in sales of
these
subscriptions um in the next 12
months if we were trying to Sprint
towards that goal that's a lot of how I
would approach it high
Hing or collabing with somebody or
thinking about who I could get help with
to build out some of these other
functions paid advertising perhaps on
some ugc because you have 7,000 or
whatever and and then what does that
look like sending them an email
contacting them and offering money by
the way and then that's also how they
this like hey we just have the rights to
use this to post it organically or to
post it but you could pay people if your
video is like decent enough I'll pay you
100 bucks if your video is great and it
ends up like working for our terms I'll
pay $250 so it's not like a lot of risk
necessarily and and you just see what
comes in and then you might be like whoa
this is amazing and think about how much
leverage that is too because by the way
if somebody who is making vertical video
content all day every day and they're
aspiring to be an influencer or just
content on their phone and you slide in
their DM sounds weird with a uh
real offer to give them $250 give them
$100 to assemble a story one day you
kidding me you hit me up at 21 25 30
like okay tomorrow I'm gonna I was gonna
create social media content anyway so
I'm just gonna like film my morning
workout and d and then like tell the
story and and so you you may like you
know make a little page describing what
you're after and set the terms and
there's not a lot of risk there there's
only upside and a couple of those
vertical assets could could be
interesting for your site for your own
platforms but then eventually for paid
ads they could be used probably for the
next three years and 10 probably but I
mean like for sure the next three and
you just keep building those up what
what's your thoughts on some of my um
strategy here um there's a tiny bit of a
chicken in the egg thing the 7,000
students who are using my stuff I can't
really directly work with them because
they're students in a school and
there're all issues of privacy and stuff
like that what I need to do is get the
independent students of whom I only have
a handful who are enthusiastic about
what I'm doing and that's possible
that's definitely possible I like that
idea um you know it's funny I I've like
I I've zealously read everything by
Donald Miller about marketing and I
really try to you know create my website
as a hero's journey but I really
appreciate the feedback because um I
probably could use a lot of professional
touchup to make that a little bit
clearer you know if you confuse you lose
and it sounds like you know you didn't
get it right away and that that tells me
something that's really powerful so um
these are ideas I'm spending a lot of my
time making shorts and you know trying
to upload a weekly video and I'm not
sure if that effort is more is is the
most directly leverageable thing that I
could be doing towards getting to my
other goals so it's this has been super
interesting as we land the plane I
really appreciate you Glenn love Donald
Miller all of his stuff is great yeah
you're you're crushing it's cool to see
what you're doing and I kind of feel
like I mean not only are you winning
already but in a way you're 3 feet from
gold it's like a hard 3 feet because
there's some things to implement and
execute but you've already built up so
much um I think
that uh the the opportunity I would
encourage you might sound a little
different than the typical YouTube
advice I would give
because when people come to me I always
want to give I can only do this in this
nuance example directly talking to you
understanding these different details
about your business because of the
nature of this
conversation but it might shock people
to to hear that like I would argue
YouTube is not always the answer you
know for the YouTube Secrets guy YouTube
is not always the answer like YouTube's
already it's a piece of your overall
strategy but it's like not the only
thing and it's what are we ultimately
trying to achieve and I always like to
encourage people
achieve F make a plan to buy your time
back to scale your business to generate
more revenue and for sometimes people
are saying I'm trying you know I'm not
quite getting the right leads from
YouTube I'm like that's not even the
actions I would take I would go to your
LinkedIn contacts message 10 people a
day I'd go through the phone numbers on
your phone call your most you know
talking about somebody else and coaching
and and have a strategy to be blunt get
money now like literally what is the
marketing business activities that would
lead to the most because when you look
at YouTube and media just take like the
hosis for example Alex and Lea horos
YouTube they lose massive amounts of
money from their YouTube te technically
te technically they lose a ton of money
from
YouTube in terms of the output and
they're spending close to like a quarter
million dollars a month in content staff
editors it's pretty crazy they call it a
lost leader though right because
acquisition. comom the scope and scale
of the business is such a bigger play so
what's interesting is their investment
though in media still reveals the same
conviction that yes their investment in
YouTube YouTube is a smart like no
matter we got to master the code here
but what's interesting is I think your
YouTube
game I I would I think there could be
some evolution in the
thumbnails I think that um I I'm not a
huge fan of these blue I definitely
understand in your Niche only look at
the stuff on top all this stuff is is
ancient two years old okay so we're just
came back to yeah the ones are
definitely much more beautiful okay
that's great so so I mean uh I think
that what's what what gets interesting
for all of us and we all Aspire if we
could hire an editor if we could hire a
designer if we could afford no problem
$15 a thumbnail from fiverr.com these
are systems we could install in our
business well that's all solved by
solving the revenue problem like if if
we've got enough money for the mission
people perish without Vision but the
vision perishes without money and if we
have enough money for the mission then
not only can you impact more people help
more people Ace their AP Bio exam like
do all of this kind of stuff but you're
able to just scale it and the direct
path to scale in my opinion is you know
as we discussed some other marketing
things YouTube is well but there might
just be some straight shot things I do
in regards to also doing website funnels
maybe some paid ads getting that all
working and then that just creates more
and YouTube's a marathon not a Sprint
it's always about building brand yes
there's some direct things we can do to
drive sales but sometimes it's quicker
to do some Essentials in in marketing as
we discussed has today's conversation
been helpful Glenn super helpful super
helpful I think that my weakness is that
I actually love the details like I love
editing and I love shooting video and I
could spend the whole day like mucking
around with Final Cut Pro to make that
cut just perfect but I think if I want
to achieve some of my other goals I need
to be working at a much more strategic
level level and that's it's not the
easiest thing I'm a biology teacher by
trade so I've got to move into a new
kind of thinking Glenn it's super
inspiring to see what you're doing um
this conversation's been valuable for
everybody in the coffee with can
community and thank you so much for
being a part of V Elite thank
you friends what has been your aha
moment I've got nine questions to get
through so we're going to be doing that
here on the coffee with canel show what
is your aha AA moment though from
today's conversations what have you been
reminded to put into action we're not
here just getting information we are
here thinking about how are we taking
action um what are you
drinking
coffee for sigmatic mushroom blend
colostrum
plus okay um smash
like if you're on Facebook shout me out
where you watching from aha funnels
versus websites always coffee Josh
cheers my man Josh the homie bro yes
exactly always coffee entertainment and
education together uh produces results I
love it um okay coffee with collagen
it's a good move Louisiana in the house
I'm coming to you from Las Vegas hey by
the way have you already joined our
YouTube challenge if you haven't if you
go to the website tube 1K challenge.com
what you're going to see by the way just
so you know what this is too this is a
funnel not a website it is one campaign
not a website we talked about this
earlier that you can sign up for and
when you sign up with your name and
email though here's what I know about
you you want to learn YouTube I mean I
mean I kind of know that because you're
here but like you know and then when I
have your email though the cool thing is
like like Glenn we want to serve and
help people and like Glenn we do have
something you can buy but if you never
buy it that's fine too but at least we
know who you are we have permission to
continue continue to talk to you so
that's just kind of
like meta I'm just taking you right into
exactly what this is so this isn't this
is not my website this is a landing page
that what is it who's it for when is it
now we're only one day into the
challenge so I want to encourage you if
you go here you click join Here sign up
um and we are giving away Deep dive
sessions I went over an hour today 125
slides talking about the asq method
tomorrow I don't know what the session
is I forget but it's really good uh
tomorrow we have special guests so
they're going to be sharing what they
wish they knew when they started from
two very successful YouTube content
creators so you're not going to want to
miss this but it's only streaming inside
of the group it's not streaming publicly
on YouTube so two 1K challenge is how
you get access to that highly
recommended and let's hit a couple of
your questions on today's coffee with
canel show what's been the biggest
misstep in your YouTube Journey
um I think
that the cool thing I like about life
John is man I make missteps all the time
I think I'm not afraid of missteps
because I have a core belief sometimes
you
win sometimes you
learn so I've made the biggest I've made
hundreds thousands of missteps
I think the mindset I like to have for
myself is I just don't want to keep
making the same mistakes I don't mind
making mistakes I just don't want to
keep making them once I observe
them um I do think that one of the
biggest mistakes or challenges for
long-term creators creators like me with
a channel that is 2.5 million
subscribers and it's 13 years
old I think what can be hard with a
really older channel is how diverse your
content is and as a result how much that
can mix up who your subscribers are let
me give you an example we have a video
posted
on um a Final Cut Pro
tutorial so that's great watch this it's
on brand because it's the best tips and
tools for growing your influence with
online video what's one of the tools
Final Cut what's one of the ways to do
it Final Cut it's a net positive but the
problem is um if you think really deeply
about this stuff over years and decades
if someone watches that one video though
and they click subscribe there may not
be another video that comes out from
think media that they actually want to
watch and that can C cause a problem
we've obviously survived our company is
heavier healthier than ever the bigger
picture of the game we're playing it's
totally fine but the re the reality
is that even your Niche within a niche
played out over time can just create a a
an an audience of subscribers that's
still a little bit mixed every time you
go a little bit off of brand or your
core core core brand may there's another
way to put it and but here's the thing I
don't regret it and honestly we still do
it it's like this is why I'm glad we
have hundreds of thousands of emails in
specific categories of people so you're
asking it's not that as a business we
are not if you will tagging and
categorizing and thinking about who
we're talking to it's that on YouTube
it's giant mix so on a YouTube video you
can invite somebody to something that
lets you know exactly who they are oh
this is a group of real estate agents
this is a group of mothers this is a
group so there's like also ways to solve
that but that's YouTube
specific um and I think also thinking
about how to solve that is what are
people being invol invited to meaning
what is the long-term this is why like
my friend's co-author of YouTube Secrets
Benji Travis and his wife Judy Travis
they actually still have a family Vlog
that's over 10 years old why people are
invested in the characters harder to do
but you're not just you're not invested
as much in a paino you're actually
following a character Evolution sounds
funny when we're talking about like
reality TV like a vlog but if you can
pull that off then you could have fans
that have watched you for 10 years now
mind you I have fans that have watched
me for 10 years as well but what videos
do they click on what and and so I'm all
those are some of the questions so it's
not even really a Mis that this is all
educational for me and I can pass along
those learnings to you this is why I'm
excited about this very think media
podcast channel for the time being it is
more focused and more dialed in than
even our other channel and even with
only 130,000 subscribers it's
interesting to see some of the results
and some of the views why because it's
also fresh by the way this opportunity
for new
creators it's a blessing to grow a new
Channel right now now mind you it's a
blessing to have a million subscribers
as well but not everything is always
what but it seems
some we actually went through an
experiment once where we took over a
channel that had 100,000 subscribers and
we saw it wasn't as powerful as you
think the question is who are the
subscribers what is it they wanted to
watch what you know you can have quote
unquote a dead Channel there's ways to
revive it but there's always different
metrics behind the scenes so that's one
to think about I think the takeaways for
all of us and is to think about what is
it we're building who is subscribing why
are they subscribing and some is it's
accepting that it might be temporary and
you're not watching think media if
you're looking for a camera you weren't
subscribing like you were to follow
Benji and Judy's Vlog you're look you
want to watch the evolution of their
family their marriage and their kids
what are they subscribing for you like
their personality you're you know
Filipino as well you kind of like the
culture you want to see different things
those are all value
propositions I have to be okay with my
friend told me one time
time Chase and CH Jason Chelsea said
Sean here's why I hate think
media you ready for this that's a great
way for your friends to open a sentence
hey Sean here's why I hate think
media I watched your channel
religiously for four months because I
wanted to upgrade my camera equipment
okay go on Jace and it was so helpful I
figured out exactly what camera
equipment I wanted to buy what
microphone what gear
and then I ordered it all and I Ed your
affiliate links thanks bro I appreciate
you so uh are you going to get to the
hate part because so far this is pretty
positive but I'm really nervous for
what's coming next so he said but then
after four months after I ordered the
camera and I had it shipped to my house
I made a conscious decision I wasn't
gonna watch your channel anymore and I
was like ouch bro like why he goes
because I realized you're always talking
about the newest thing and the newest
camera and I didn't want to have fear of
missing out because now I have my camera
and I watched the tutorial of how to use
it so now I'm just going to go do the
work and thank you but I don't want to
be reminded that there's a new Sony
camera out and and so by the way in
terms of ideation and insight this is
why as much conversations with actual
audience members as you can be in give
you invaluable insights because the
Creator who understands the viewer best
wins so then I started thinking two
things one how do I solve that problem
two being okay with okay in a lot of
ways think media is can be
transitory people come for a while they
learn they get what they need they go
execute and so they might not be as
active as a subscriber as somebody this
is why there's a million-dollar YouTube
question this is a big
one this is a juicy coffee with
canel are you you ready for me okay like
just Hypes it up like takes 10 minutes
like T okay this is it's a it's a
serious question so what content could
you create on YouTube that would make
viewers want to come back and genuinely
watch every
day you don't have to do that I'm just
saying it if you if you have a good
answer to that question that actually
works you've created one of the most
valuable things in the
world let's go to level
two what question what content could you
create on YouTube
that people would want to watch for the
next 5 to 10
years not everyone can answer that and
you don't even have to you might go my
Niche doesn't fit in that totally fine
just when you if you think about brand
and Legacy those are some interesting
thought exercises okay do people come to
my channel to learn one thing get the
answer to the question and move on if
that's true that's fine but you should
adapt accordingly okay so I do
definitely need new acquisition to keep
growing because people will pass pass
through is this more of they stick with
me and I'm trying to build a fan base
okay that's interesting and will the fan
base age out and will there need to be
new acquisition or could I like build a
mob that rolls with me for the next five
to 10
years just trying to make you think on
the coffee with canel show that question
went too deep honestly and um I mean
hopefully it was valuable but I but
smash like because this was going to be
a lightning round and I took 38 minutes
to answer that question as we land the
plane on seven more questions Chris good
to see you bro what books you recommend
for people who need structure in their
day as a small video business for a
small video business great question um
there is one book let's start with the
one if you're going to read
one uh managing your day today we'll
link it up in the show
notes that's not the title let me
actually get it for you I'm going to
share screen oh yeah this one's a good
book it's short too which is nice when
you're busy
so uh here you go for managing your
day-to-day I recommend managing your
day-to-day so build your routine find
your focus sharpen your creative
mind really cool book little guy it's a
little seven inch
book uh two it's still 253 pages but the
pages are smaller and this was in the
99u so
bski
um Scott
bski another one I put in the list if
you're watching this on the replay we'll
have all these in the description for
you Scott
bellii book Scott making ideas happen
boom so making ideas happen these were
fundamental creative books for me to
mature as a creative so I like you um
was by the way here's my little
hack8 bucks for the hard cover I don't
know if there that a print or something
so what I would do on Amazon is I would
hit the use section up right here then
what I do and by the way not trying to
like Flex but like I'm I'm doing okay
financially
now you might take the kid out of the
small town but you never take the small
town out of the kid I'm still Balling on
a budget I shop used books like crazy
like I could just sometimes for Speed I
want the prime but what I do is I go in
here and I'm going to go very good pages
are clean I probably grab that one text
is free from that'd be the one 550 now
you're gonna pay shippings it's gonna be
like eight bucks so um you know instead
of paying 28 for the hard cover now like
new is the hack though so like new six
bucks I go a little further it's barely
more money pages are clean not marred
Thrift Books Phoenix boom like new pages
are clean there's another Thrift Books
Okay who cares just a little hack for
you that I personally do so making ideas
happen overcoming the obstacles between
vision and
reality uh those two are are are really
great and then I think Atomic habits
would be um another one and then there's
there's a lot of great productivity
books out there uh take the stairs by
Rory Vaden so those that one that is a
very profound book not not take the
stairs nope nope do not buy Rory vaden's
book BR take the
stairs you can buy that one too but get
procrastinate on purpose that's the
that's the one so let's recap the
managing your day-to-day making ideas
happen Atomic habits procrastinate on
purpose five permissions to multiply
your time multiply your time so man this
framework and Rory's good friend he's
been on the podcast a couple times we're
going to have him back on the podcast um
coming up soon so side note Drea if
you're listening to this have Daisy hit
Rory up again let's just I mean it'll be
like three months until he's on but we
should just get it scheduled because
Roy's a legend so those are four of them
and we'll link those up in the
description um but great question
appreciate you Chris look forward to
seeing you soon in Vegas um would it be
better to get my branding trademarked
first and then get an LLC
first well that's a personal question do
you think someone's going to steal your
brand have you researched the brand is
it even tra tradem markable um different
things go into that I know different
trademarks could be in different states
is it like Nationwide I'm not an
attorney do you have the money are you
committed to this for the next 5 10 15
20 years do you think it's important is
there a big threat of somebody that
could come against you because you might
get first movers kind of Advantage if
you just don't worry about it um those
are also kind of two different questions
should I get a trademark or an
LLC
well you should get an LLC so whether
you get a trademark or not so I mean yes
uh but for sure on the LLC we have a
cool
resource um that is a must take
advantage of if you haven't set up your
LLC our resource is what's the link to
that
Rea um we'll link to this episode
with
Tommy from Prime Corporate
Services we actually have a
connection if you go to think Prime
LLC you can get a free LLC now you do
have to pay the state taxes but they'll
they'll give you Consulting on your
specific situation really cool firm
Prime Corporate Services I believe
they're based in Utah team of a couple
hundred people kind of a business
partner of ours and they they will give
you a free strategy session and at the
end of of it if you need help with taxes
they've got some stuff if you need a
more advanced corporate structure they
can help if you need lines of credit or
business funding or asset protection so
I think discussing with them the if you
even really need to do the trademark is
definitely worth your time because the
the call is free so if you go to
think
um Prim llc.com is where you can take
advantage
of that so let me put that up for you
and and get the LLC for sure because
that's liability protection and wisdom
is wisdom as well as it is a little bit
helpful for the
IRS
because they
um you can write stuff off without an
LLC if you
itemize but what you want to show the
IRS is that you have declared you have
intent
you're organizing your business expenses
you've got the liability
protection and getting the right pieces
in order is um is always nice like of
all the guests we've had on they also
just say being organized is probably one
of the biggest
Keys like Sonia and my wife just got
some sticky
notes little colored
circles because we have a couple
different business credit cards sorry
Dave
um but we pay our balance off all the
time yeah that's stupid okay Dave I'm
but like we actually just got approv for
the new AMX business we're on a waiting
list doesn't matter um and so but it's
organized because we we spend money in
our real estate business we spend money
in our business business we have
personal expenses and the way we
organize those things the way that we
can log into the app and categorize
things so much tax
savings so much also organization that
the right things are in the right places
so anyways think Prime llc.com help you
do a strategy session for your business
totally free that's a partner of ours
and uh it will be incredible information
for you um and
potentially there might be some uh
deeper levels that they could help you
as well great question um okay I don't
know why my shorts are not going viral
could having a logo of your shorts
reduce visibility I wouldn't put a logo
on your
shorts I would assume that also means
you're selecting a custom thumbnail on
the app I think it's going to be
about there's a lot of things we could
diagnose and typically I wouldn't do
this but I'm
fascinated let's go see why let's see
what we could fix with one of your
shorts are electric sky taxis the future
of urban
[Music]
travel Joy a okay that part right there
just killed
The Experience whatever just happened
there so job Aviation our electric sky
taxis the future of urban
travel like even that hook kind of sucks
like this would be interesting
if um it had that Tik Tock voice now the
voice is fine but if it had that like
Tik Tock voice and it was like what we
want is more like a fifth grade headline
like this plane is a helicopter or this
new plane like something that's really
good as opposed to because it's kind of
so you have a hook the hook didn't
really gra the hook was not very good
now the visual is decent because it's
kind of like oh cool that's a weird
helicopter
thing this part is a killer of retention
because I got to reread the text you
just echoed the title you're wasting my
time and I'm I'm on I'm I'm gone I
almost franchised one of those froz to
something that's going to grab my
attention so like like that moment jobby
Aviation our electric sky job aviation's
meaningless taxis the future of so
even if the Tik Tock girl goes are
electric sky taxis the future of
Aviation and you maybe changed the scene
once or twice that that would be a
better hook
skip get this waste of time kills for
attention Joby Aviation stands at the
Forefront of the Aerospace industry
poised to reshape the future of urban
Mobility they're pioneering electric
vertical take the rest of this is pretty
good um side note I have a subwoofer
it's not a huge deal but your plosives
are really intense I can theives are
shaking my whole room which is like a
pop filter thing and how you're
recording your voice over it's no big
deal though most people aren't going to
hear that on their phone because there's
no subwoofer and Landing aircraft Evo is
a testament to Innovation blending
Cutting Edge technology with sustain
sustainability these Sleek all electric
vehicles promise to revolutionize Urban
Transportation reducing congestion and
carbon emissions while offering Swift
and efficient travel mind you with a
vision for a world with a on mobile it's
a little bit different but notice your
captions they could be more Center
screen they're covered by the title on a
desktop experience but even still I like
to bring my captions more Center I think
the b roll should be changing a lot more
I think that you should be changing the
scene more and then I think you just
have to judge the total value of the
story itself pretty good and if he got
in front of the Right audience I think
with the right hook then someone might
hang on this information but I think the
quality of the story maybe the drama or
tying things into it it there there's no
conflict here so what do story what do
good stories have or all story like they
have characters they have conflict they
have Rising conflict they maybe open up
a loop the loop I could be could this be
the future of travel if so you could tie
in um the New York Governor just said
just approve the first cars now cars are
going to be flying in the sky you could
show some futuristic AI renderings of
some stuff that's outrageous there could
be a lot more things that that make the
story gripping and that maybe put some
open Loops you want to include drama so
then who's an enemy uh but not not
everyone's a fan of of the airmobile of
these Sky taxis in fact the governor of
D is trying to shut them down claiming
that they're dangerous and after the
first one had two deaths like so there's
just a lot ways a lot of ways that this
could be taken to a whole another level
um and so there's one short for you I
don't know that's those improvements
could help your shorts go
viral what if you're a cat channel the
kind of courses do you offer to others
you
don't I like that you asked that
question because we teach multiple
different business models but not every
business model works for every Niche so
some people bang their head against the
wall they go Sean you told me to do
affiliate marketing but it doesn't work
for my Niche and I go no I didn't tell
you to do affiliate marketing I can see
how you could come to that conclusion
because I talk about it a lot but had I
understood the right money plan for
you I would have not encouraged you so
if you are a cat entertainment Channel
as your name
suggests courses is not going to be a
linear thing that you could sell now
maybe there could be a bridge because
courses on how to train your cat do
sell
but usually it's off an education
Channel itself so for example one of our
students McCain dogs now a lot of people
they came to grow a video live we've
talked connected a couple times I mean
obviously a million subscribers now but
one of the things that they've created
is programs so they sell courses like
crazy online three months access
$97 but the actual intent of the channel
is attracting people that want to be
educated if you're in
entertainment I think sometimes there's
an argument for just big views go viral
compilations compilations of OPC other
people's content a lot of stuff we talk
about that in V
Masters um Andor you could do feature
accounts like have you ever seen
um you ever follow like office addict on
Instagram or cat's accounts or like
fashion accounts or meme accounts you
know how they monetize they gather huge
audiences of
humans generic humans that sounds kind
of funny but like if it's a meme account
it's like everybody it's not like a a
dog parents who want to get trained and
subscribe to McCain dogs it's people who
just like funny stuff but then what do
they sell you follow those accounts you
could study this on Instagram they sell
like weird dumb stuff that everybody
wants so you grow the channel big enough
and like brand deals could be like weird
stuff for the house or weird C
accessories or weird cat like you just
the key is understanding your audience
and understanding what they'd
potentially be interested in to buy and
so if you not only could you go maybe
what are some physical products you
could be an affiliate for or drop ship
to customers like whatever business
model you want to
build um but on the flip side if I'm
just generally in for just kind of
entertaining internet type of content
and there's like something super cool
like oh my gosh this popsocket for my
smartphone makes it the phone stand up
on its own and take selfies like every
human wants every human has a phone so
like a phone
accessory thinking about these brands or
products that are have good broad appeal
and I would you you have a lot more
opportunity there than trying to like
convert people to purchase a
course off of when they're watching
entertainment and that is not the main
thing they want can you briefly explain
a funnel Brian good question I mean a
funnel versus a website is a website a
website's weakness is too many
options the a website is more like
there's there's lots of lay the best
practices but a
website can
ultimately um home about book podcast
I'm going to sneak around on the site
think about what I want to click on I
could do lots of different things I
could watch some videos I don't know
where I want to go totally fine but like
that's a
website a funnel is quite
literally starts wide and like like
forces people down into a certain
direction should they continue to want
to go that way and it would be like true
in the in real life like the freeway
goes from five Lanes to four lanes to
eventually hey coming up is a stoplight
you ever been like our freeway ends and
then you get to the light and then you
have to go you know this next Direction
so it's truly kind you're leading
somebody around basically around One
path or perhaps there's a couple choices
in the in in the journey
so in the world of funnels there's
things called like webinar funnels book
funnels uh free product funnels trip
wire funnels you get different types of
funnels challenge funnels um and they
all they're to to lead people down a
particular direction towards a
particular goal um and there's not going
to be a hundred decisions on the website
there's G to be like one decision on the
website so even if there could product
funnels would
be
um
organifi I'll I'll end the plane on this
question land the plane on this question
best greens powder organifi has a
um has
a website but they also
have a
me go find the classic video this video
is generated like 20 grand so powder
this video goes
to a funnel that is dead now let me see
if I can find
organifi see what this is so this is a
website fine e-commerce you could see
all the different products for for
organifi okay cool
great um I can't actually find the site
but I'm looking for because it looks
like it's it's down but let me see if we
can actually find so there's again
multiple different
options what it used to be was it was
like one page for one product and it
just LED straight
to um and it no longer exists so I think
I I recently bought like some
dumbbells um I bought a massage gun from
a funnel and you know what ended up
happening this true story so it was a
really nice massage gun
and they led me through the there was
only one thing to do wasn't a web page
it was
like text and things encouraging me if I
wanted to buy a massage gun so I bought
it so I enter my name and I credit card
information I bought the gun you know
what happened on the next page do you
want to buy another gun for 50% off and
I was like shoot dude that's a great
price that's a great gift idea for Sony
and I's friends Katherine there her and
Tom are athletic and they would love
this I do want to buy
another um gun by the way that's an Otto
a one that's a one-time offer Otto to an
upsell something else to buy then they
said do you want to extend your warranty
to like 10 years for 20 bucks and I was
like yeah so I added that to card as
well then they were like check this out
this is a bolt-on of a different
business then they were like I can't
remember what it was but it was like a
pivot do you also
want this other fitness equipment or
this education stuff related to Fitness
I didn't want that so I said no but what
what they might learn in a funnel too
see that doesn't happen on a website now
it could on a website you purchase
something but a funnel is like all of
the things it's like where it starts
there's an offer you could purchase
something maybe you add something to it
and and similarly you'll see aspects of
this in different places too that that
that would be blending what we'd call a
sales process if you're checking out if
you happen to be buying a car online
from Ford aren't they going to get you
or actually in the dealership too
they're like so you also want the uh the
such and such coverage for 300 you know
you're like yeah you're like did you
want the all weather package for the
things you're like okay and did you want
this as well you're like I'm already
overspending I might as well have that
too like so anyways a lot of things go
into it I think it's worth researching
but businesses typically need both but a
business that doesn't have funnels is
severely leaving a lot of opportunity on
they only have a website is missing out
on a lot of opportunity how can you sell
to uh people whose attention we gain
from
entainment
um if you're asking how can you sell to
people who don't have like a good
attention
span a number one you should avoid
trying
meaning get in front of more qualified
leads are better potential
customers
so I this claimer I'm not saying it's
impossible to sell to people with if you
will shorter attention spans but perhaps
we're again trying to solve the wrong
problem why not make that problem
unnecessary by just getting in front of
people who have better attention spans
which could have to do with the
demographics psychographics of people
who are attracting could have to do with
the type of cont
like we're we're noticing some things
right now where YouTube shorts gives you
the ability to click through to to
connect a related video and have it
click
through we're kind of excited about it
but we're also leery because the watch
time because you could see the video we
sent to we can see the traffic Source
works but the actual watch time there is
lower while people came over with a
shorts
mentality that's all fine but here's my
point what wouldn't it be better to
connect with somebody who is a more
in-depth richer learner open to already
like if you could just skip skip the
whole process skip straight to people
with better attention
spans why not skip straight to qualified
prospects qualified leads that would be
the better goal in answer to your direct
question build a new skill set learn how
to
storytellin a more if they're expecting
entertainment be more entertaining level
up your storytelling level up your humor
level up your ability to hold people's
attention level up um your content
itself you're editing how much it holds
people's attention and notice what we
just
did I actually prefaced it by
saying just get in front of better
customers because that would arguably
also be easier because I'm into number
two as well improve everything become a
better story become more charismatic a
better story teller more entertaining
but that second part you might go well
that's freaking hard dude like what are
you talking Sean relax bro like what do
you mean just easier said than n well
for sure so rather than try to win
arguably unwinable games or much more
difficult games position yourself to be
in games that you're going to win by
default like again imagine like when you
ultimately when you think about making
it I think about places where I purchase
things
um and where it has nothing to do with
the quality of sales it's because like
I'm already pre I'm like the easiest
close if I'm already convinced I've
already done so then the key would just
be get in front of customers like me in
the right environment and it's a
friction free sale and in instead of
like having harder prospects to convert
number two just takes more skill
building more hard work I encourage that
as well but it's gonna be a little bit
more difficult okay as we land the plane
smash like button we'll do a couple more
questions here coffee with K how you
feeling
we're an hour and 26 minutes into it I'm
going to save my energy end here pretty
soon because we're back tomorrow for the
challenge
at 10: am Pacific Standard Time session
number two there is still time to sign
up 21k challenge.com if you're just
joining if you're watching on Facebook
if you're here on YouTube and you're not
signed
up make a decision you're not going to
regret I don't want you to look
back January 1 and be like man 2023 was
all
right but I should have done that
YouTube challenge shoot just imagine
yourself on New Year sitting there and
being like yeah my family's cool my kids
are all right but I should have done
that challenge why did I miss
that I'm only half joking so listen tube
1K challenge.com like is where it's at
we have four more sessions it's entirely
free Tuesday is session number two you
can watch the replay of session number
one on demand right now by the way so if
you join here you could go and watch
session number one and Link in the
description down below you could be a
part of the rest of it we're B we're
giving away a complete YouTube Studio
camera lighting we're giving away we
gave away a shotgun microphone today a
road Wireless go a membership to vid IQ
all kinds of giveaways so much cool
stuff happening there's a whole private
group in a platform called
Circle to 1K challenge.com
all right friends last
question if you had to make one YouTube
video right now how long would you make
it for sure I'd make it over eight
minutes and you might say because you
want multiple ad spots well yes um but
honestly just because one because why
not why would you not want the
opportunity to have multiple ad spots by
the way although we have in the past and
we do sometimes times on Ultra long form
videos we don't like force multiple ad
spots in videos Nolan does sometimes in
his uh on his other channel but what we
do is we just check the box of like
let's look at by the way one of my most
recent
videos that I really sat down and
crafted is is popping off it's doing
very well um and back to bidy Farmers
what we were talking to earlier this is
kind of what I would recommend I do
video podcasting as well because of its
sustainability but this video this
wasn't an accident I sat down I scripted
it shot it multiple angles editing
reviewed revisions thumbnail concept
really put the work into it because I
wanted to reverse engineer success and
sure enough not that it's like a
guarantee every time but but it is if
you follow the perfect video recipe and
that's you know what happened here the
video popped off um what's my point the
point is it's over 8 minutes and then
the point is it gives you the
opportunity to do during mid roll ads
skippable ads and if we manage these mid
rolls I mean honestly there's not even
any in there uh there's just the one at
the end
which I guess is an opportunity to go
back but that's at least what it says
there this is all I'm saying is if you
just check all the boxes before and
after and then during um YouTube does it
on their own so the algorithm push an ad
and here's what I mean it sounds bad but
like in a in a non- negative way YouTube
won't always show
ads they are optimizing for viewer
experience so even just because you put
a spot in there doesn't mean it'll be
shown and there's ad blockers and
they're cracking down and all that stuff
anyways my point is just check all the
boxes and if it's over eight minutes you
have the opportunity to earn more
money and so that's thing one I would
for sure make it over eight minutes if I
was only going to make one YouTube video
right now
though I would work backwards from I
guess all else being equal if I had the
time to do this you know and work on
this I would work backwards from making
a hero
video that's 18 to 25
minutes that's like an episode of The
Office that every minute's crafted and I
think the word
to understand it is that it's kind of
a a video essay or a mini documentary
now it maybe just me be me be me
teaching the whole time but let's end
coffee with canel with this trend that
is for sure happening on YouTube there's
we can debate all day long about quality
versus quantity but there is a big
opportunity in quality right now and
longer form quality so just my honest
answer to the question is
15 minutes 25 minutes around that range
whatever it comes out to be but that's
kind of what I'd be shooting for a topic
that supports that title and a lot of
energy put into it to do what I did with
the AI video to reverse engineer a video
that's going to be a banger that takes
me more energy to craft because that
energ that video took me more energy to
craft like it's way different than just
jumping on an interview on a video
podcast which what I like is
sustainability repurpose across depends
on what you want to achieve but if
you're isolating me into just the
YouTube world because you that's what
you asked one YouTube
video I would really sit down and craft
a video that by the way not only could
potentially pop off like this and this
is only eight
minutes but that could keep going at the
trajectory it's on to generate 14400
bucks
$2,100 150,000 views I think we'll see
it there plus Affiliates from this AI
software and some other things that are
happening so backyard barn finds I hope
that's helpful and uh we also had a
Super Chat come in from fireside chat no
questions at all just showing my
appreciation of the channel much love
super grateful and truly coffee with
Kel um the fact y'all are here live
either on Facebook or YouTube I see you
Moon bean and Bruiser and um thanks so
much for the Super Chat and wiita super
grateful for y'all if you're on the
replay hit me with the hashtag Replay
famam in the comments by the way I go
back and I read everyone and I'm always
blown away because we're an hour and 33
minutes and 25 seconds into this and
uh that's kind of crazy um for you to be
here on the replay but I do appreciate
you um definitely the next move because
we'll be able to hang out a lot more in
a circumstances like this is a sign up
for the challenge to 1K challenge.com
and if you are just jumping on I highly
recommend watching the replay and
there's some Banger show notes on this
episode somebody asked about the four
books to get your productive life your
your day-to-day life in order and I
recommended some books I haven't talked
about before those are in the
description we talked about um some
really cool I forget I mean I got to
drink more coffee but some different
videos that we link to uh as well and
some episodes as well as the challenges
down there streamyard is down there a
bunch of other cool stuff so definitely
check out the show notes in the
description my name is Sean canel rhymes
with YouTube channel this is the coffee
with canel show subscribe like and I
cannot wait to see you in a future
episode cheers